la neige recouverte par les ordures dans
les rues de madrid les poubelles
s'amoncellent jusqu'à empêcher les
passants de circuler c'est un quartier
où il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées
c'est devenu très compliqué de marché
dans la famille il ya plein de cartons
il ya tellement de sacrifices par devoir
quitter le trottoir pour marcher sur la
chaussée
même s'il ya déjà de plus en plus de
voitures qui circulent les fortes
intempéries de samedi dernier ont rendu
impossible l'accès aux rues de la
capitale espagnole alors pour tenter de
dégager la route
les madrilènes retroussent leurs manches
il dégage seulement les rues principales
celle ci comme vous pouvez le voir dans
une pièce de recouverte de neige même
s'il ya un borgne vers le service de
ramassage des ordures n'est même pas non
plus depuis vendredi dernier
nous accumulons les déchets chez l'homme
car les camions ne peuvent pas passer
les habitants invitent leurs voisins à
ne plus jeter leurs poubelles dans la
rue selon les médias locaux jusqu'à 9000
tonnes de déchets n'ont pas pu être
ramassés c'est à tel point que les
commerçants craignent de ne plus pouvoir
ouvrir leurs magasins dans un jour et
demi les ordures vont recouvrir la
vitrine
simon serre ont tous un peu les coudes
je pense qu'il est possible de dégager
un espace pour permettre aux gens de
traverser tous ensemble je pense qu'on
peut y arriver mais c'est très très
compliqué samedi dernier madrid a été
balayée par la tempête philomena la
ville n'avait pas connu de chute de
neige aussi importante depuis 50 ans